c'est dans cette maison située dans un
hameau d'une centaine d'habitants que
les deux corps ont été retrouvés mardi
matin ceux d'un homme et d'une femme
d'une cinquantaine d'années séparés
depuis un an le couple était en instance
de divorce avec lui-même il n'avait idée
et puis je ne m'attendais jamais ce que
aujourd'hui japonais
alerté par l'un des fils du couple les
enquêteurs ont découvert un fusil à
proximité des corps selon les premières
constatations le quinquagénaire aurait
tiré sur sa compagne avant de retourner
l'armé contre lui
une hypothèse qui surprend l'entourage
je les connaissais depuis longue date
plus de 20 ans bon j'ai toujours été
amis avec eux et avec elles des tensions
que mon vin il était c'est une personne
qui était commet pas mal de déprime dès
mon arrivée à ce tact là n'ont pour
l'heure si la piste de l'homicide suivi
d'un suicide semble privilégiée
il faudra encore attendre les résultats
des autopsies pour la confirmer le
parquet de dijon a ouvert une enquête
c'est désormais à la brigade de
gendarmerie de beaune de faire toute la
lumière sur les circonstances de ce
drame